Chuyến tham của chú tịch nông mà có sang ra via Chyss La Volodym tởi vì giữa ngành mỗi thương tảm,
lấy gió mỗi bức đi mởi chú tính chuyền cùng có quanh hiện ngà chú tiền.
Thái mà tổng thống ra đi miệp cuốn chiến, ông Volodym chuyển thông đẹp chúc mừng nhân kiến nghiệm
tảm i năm ngày giải phóng và khẳng định mắt gavà sẵn sàng tăng cửa tác đến liviển.
Bất thương của tổng thống cuốn chiến nhận mạnh, mỗi con để hỗng y ý và hợp tà sông phương tý tụp phát triển.
Nhân là sau khi hà bên kỹ nghiệp ước đối tác chi lượng tòn diện, năm nay ngày nguyên không trai mít hơn.
Về phí trường tiền, ngã lánh đào kým trường yên người lời cảm ơn và phần định.
Truyến tham của ông Volodym là cơ hội tăng cửa tình cải chính trị và mở giống gặp tác.
Hà bên tác cửa đứng phái chau của các quan là pháp, chúng Việt tạm mua trường pháp li thuận lời để chiến khai các thật thòn.
Có đau túc đẩy quanh để sống phương chiến mọi lĩnh vực.